哇 哇 恐怖 超恐怖啦
韓國股市又在熔斷了
好 今年第七次
會不會波及台股啊
你來看今天三大重點 我告訴你
韓國股市大跌 熔斷破底 怎麼辦
破季線了 台灣股市為什麼那麼強
真的可以置身事外嗎
第二個 矽晶圓
我們的矽晶圓為什麼是最強出息
我相信一定很多老師又說他有矽晶圓了
沒有關係 沒有關係
你去比較一下我們的股票為什麼那麼強
第三個是大家的台積電
最稀盈收的解讀
普货利息新高怎么看
今天三大重点我要告诉你
这独家的说秘密
不论是大盘走势
不论是个股强弱势
还有今天最弱的是被动元件
我就说我是被动元件专家
你就不信我
去想想看你要怎样分析
我一切一切
我预告在前面
韩股今天又大跌
投资朋友们都很紧张
很担心台股会不会受到牵连
到底该怎么办
台股今天波动很剧烈
但投资涨有一堆涨停满
今天投资涨的环球金
中美金和台湾No.1
这三档股票全都涨停了
而且全部都是一开盘就一架锁死
你想追都追不到
投资朋友们一定都很好奇
今天台股好像看起来表现没有很好
韩股竟然还大跌破底
但投资涨的股票
究竟为什么可以这么强呢
你手上還沒有標股嗎
還想知道更多股市八卦嗎
接下來就交給我們經濟日報選股幻居
單記188%的記錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲榮投資長
投資長好
Lily 各位投票大家好
韓國股市破底了啦
台灣股市很棒
投資廟
上禮拜很多人說
哲哲 你為什麼要怪這個市長
我說你上禮拜五如果放假你看多好
禮拜五大家Happy週末 Happy weekend
同朋友你看 我說實話啦
今天韓國股市大跌怎麼辦
你告訴我怎麼辦
來來 你告訴我怎麼辦
韓國股市這麼弱
已經這樣子
回到5月的一個地方
你看是回到5月沒錯吧
是回到5月的地方沒錯
對過去嘛 這5月
是韓國股市喔
5月喔 你們看到
好 我們看一下台灣股市的5月
台灣股市5月起漲點在這邊
4萬點
你想要跌到4萬點嗎
一直會怕
有一點耶
會怕對不對
3萬9 4萬點 問到
5月的時候3萬9 4萬點
你看一下
不要開玩笑
韓國股市跌到這邊來
台灣股市在這邊
那你說可不可以永遠置身之外
很難
幸好我們台積電營收不錯
可是韓國股市的營收不好嗎
海力是ADI大漲耶
怎麼辦
等一下再跟你講台積電最新營收
同朋友你去想看你要展完分析室喔為什麼
來我昨天晚上是不是有跟你講
有沒有看到
很多人說會大漲
我說不會
明天開完不一定會大漲600點以上有沒有看到
但是很多個股委報復興噴出
所以我告訴你我說不會大漲600點可是你算喔
禮拜五付胎值是可以漲3%喔
代表是照常說應該可以漲1000多點
聽有沒有 今天好像一度有1000多點以上嘛對不對
好像有900 1000點
同朋友 我講的重點是什麼
我已經告訴你不會大展600點 代表是今天就是開高走低的啊
因為大家都預測攢900點 1000點啊
你聽懂嗎
懂
只有我告訴你不會大展600點以上
可是我的股票還在漲停
我今天如果是老頭顧分析師
我可以講30分鐘的環球金啦
我不卸啦
為什麼
你們都知道這環球金是我的股票啊
別人要插一隻腳都沒有賺我進產那麼多啦
買那麼多次進產那麼低啦
很多投稿會表演的啦
哎呦我今天有環球精的
哎呦我今天有精彩了
你買幾塊你跟我說
我不需要
你有沒有賺的比我多你說
我不需要跟人家比
我實實在在的分析師
我跟你講我解盤就這樣子
由上而下
他不當
我告訴你很簡單
我先解總金面
我在解個股
本來就是這樣子
不然你看今天一堆股票跌下去啦
是
我問大家一件事情
人家說怎麼樣怎麼樣
我是不是說過AI股還會漲
是
我是不是說過要氣象報告
以後可能要用AI為主了
你們不相信
你們看新聞
你們自己看
8位入境終於一致
專家AI模式勝出
可是他說AI模式勝出對不對
怎麼樣
最主要的AI模式是怎麼樣
介於我說的
我最強 我比AI又強
我比傳統模式更強
我比企業主播更強
不好意思 這是我贏了
你們看AI模式是怎樣
離台灣很遠對不對
太遠了對不對
這邊太遠了對不對
對
然後咧
我就說
不要放假嘛
不要放假禮拜五多開心
禮拜五可以攢一千多點
傳統模式這邊
胡扯後來變這邊對不對
對
介於AI模式跟怎麼樣
跟傳統模式中間
只有我最準
我也告訴你不要放假
很多人說
嘖嘖有些地方下大雨
你們不要騙我啦
禮拜五台北市哪邊
你說部分山區你可以放假
這個扯遠了啦
照這樣子以後颱風假
我跟你講啦
先來一天準備假
好不好
再一天颱風假
再一天呢
是不是
再一天整理假啦
不是這樣搞的
規定是怎麼樣就是怎麼樣
只要就是很
久了就知道了
我完全不會什麼
喜歡哪個政黨不喜歡哪個政黨
你會發現我都會稍微講一下
只講多三感情
可是我要告訴你
我算是全台灣最重力的啦
沒有錯吧
我問你禮拜五要放什麼家
我就事論事啊
你看禮拜五
多少經濟損失
禮拜五到底要放什麼家你告訴我
你說禮拜六放我沒得獎
可是禮拜六其實也沒有想像中大
好強的
哇 全世界最強的颱風
籠罩整個台灣 有沒有
這個新聞啊
後來有嗎
就玩北偏了嘛
我跟你講啊
我連氣象都預測準
難怪我環球晶是暫停嘛
你告訴我全台灣最強的不就矽晶圓
你們都知道台灣No.1的資產股票
我沒揭開牌
我半買半相送啦
你們都知道跟環球晶有關係啦
你們自己知道啦
暫停你們自己知道啦
環球晶暫停啦
5483中美金一架所死啦
台湾股市今天由高到低
讲一讲我有点痛
太激动了
我还在手术还在发炎
是
他说要半年
我现在还四个月
三个月
开高走低啦
最高4万5千
最高4万6千
330点啦
差一点1000点啦
980点
有没有
开高走低最后资产37点
我一堆股票殺下去
只有我的股票一架所死
我有没有人做见证
你们告诉我全台湾最强的是谁
不就是我郭哲龙
是
我告诉你啦
你告诉我现在谁比我强
来啊
你把我打我脸
你告诉我
这两个月谁绩效比我好
不要那些
我给你来都是普通微言的简讯
我是真的很激动
可是我也很开心
你们现在知道
你看现在被动员间一堆人惨得要命
我以前是被动员间1.0 2.0
我都参与
是不是
来
再跟大家讲
中美金展庭暂停
免费送你啦
是不是
这在刚开始别激动
谢谢
这人神
来
是不是
中美金展庭版
环球金730再加码都翻倍了
你看這會員見證啊
我在730元跌停板加碼
想買幾張就買幾張
我說最好加碼
所以我就說股票跌
只要你選對股票你怕什麼
你看我十幾個展停板
你看看
你看看一個展停板
那時候五六百塊買
兩個展停板
三個展停板
四個展停板
五個展停板
六個展停板
七個展停板
八個展停板
九個展停板
這我跟別的老師不一樣
很多人說好像有很多展停板
很多表演的
展停板的時候去追展停板
你知道嗎
有些老頭顧都這樣表演的
哇 我今天有環球精展停
哇 我今天有精彩展停
我今天 啊績效多少
你告訴我績效多少嗎
你告訴我績效 100%嘛
這事實啊
有沒有像我一樣是100%嘛
我買到730元
我當天跌停就買耶
是不是
是
我掛730元買進是再買進喔
已經買進了不用再買喔
想一想不對勁
我什麼時候叫老會員也加碼
你告訴我老會員們
我什麼時候叫你們加碼
一般來想我不會叫你們加碼的啦
等一下
來
持有環球金的老會員也試單加碼
這你加碼
是
730跌停板叫一堆人買
你們不理我
到底有誰我的股票比我強啊
你們剛剛是誰
中行情 我一支獨秀
不好意思 兩支三支啊
三個五票展廳
都細菌園
你看被動元件
你看被動元件 跌停
是不是
真的很慘啊
是不是 AI氣象真強 則則比AI氣象更強
是不是
則則說實話小心被出征
我覺得有些人都很奇怪
哎呀那個哎呀哎呀那個
雇主的心態啊
什麼雇主不雇主心態
就事論事
景氣不好每天放假也不行啊
我就這樣想啊
那你要整整很混是不是
你喜歡你付錢給我
你需要某種賣命我也是為你賣命欸
是
是不是
我也少一天工作啊
少一天操作股票啊
你有比較開心嗎
你問每一個繳會費給我的希望禮拜五開盤是不開盤希望開盤是啊你們都用你們的角度看事情我看會抱怨我要講個邏輯有沒有做什麼
會抱怨說
哲哲
你不要批評政府
不要批評犯假
喔這是地方政府
我也不要講藍跟綠
你們不要把什麼做藍跟綠
哲哲
哎呀你就灌老闆
我灌老闆
你問每一個繳會費給我的
希望禮拜五開盤是不開盤
開盤
你問人家開盤啊
希望整個多工作啊
是
我不是冠老闆啊
我是你們聘請的分析師啊
不好意思我苦命啊
我還希望幫你們加班耶
對不對 你們邏輯要對
禮拜五本來就不用放假
你看為什麼禮拜五
你看你看在看一個事情
禮拜五為什麼
禮拜五為什麼不放假
你們差很多人來看一下喔
富台值有沒有看到
今天早盤展933點有沒有看到
沒錯吧
富台值為什麼點1.16%
你知道為什麼嗎
因為禮拜
這你不知道對不對
對
333點為什麼
漲2%
為什麼負財值
跌1.16%
因為代表是什麼
代表的是
負財值本來漲3%
本來3%
本來漲3%
3%減掉1%不就變2%嗎
欸 對耶
懂不懂
3%減1%不就2%
是
所以負財值漲3%
禮拜五如果台灣股市不開盤
台灣股市會漲1300點以上
3%就1300點
你懂不懂
懂不懂
快1400 知道嗎
這簡直是喔
為什麼今天早盤漲2%
我教你數學嘛
這專業嘛
好不好
台灣股市為什麼
今天漲2% 漲933點
負台值還跌1.16
因為禮拜五負台值有開
禮拜五負台值漲了3%以上
漲了3% 一度漲3%以上
漲3%
3%-1% 不就變2%
是
懂我意思吧
懂
所以如果是用3%的話
就是比933點還高
所以大概是1400多點
1400點
好多喔
所以禮拜五如果台灣股市有開盤
是很開心的1400點
真的
我講錯
沒錯
這樣懂我意思吧
所以你不要看今天是漲24點
其實是怎麼樣
你本來禮拜五你可以很開心的
是
你懂不懂
今天跌下去也沒關係
兩天加起來是漲的
這樣懂我邏輯吧
這禮拜五在不開牌
哎呀 就是認識
好不好 我看邏輯有沒有錯
參加我哪個會員的
付錢給我 叫我賣命工作的
哪一個希望我禮拜五
休息
沒錯吧 沒錯
我相信你產善為預言家
我跟你講分析師屌的就是講在前面
不要失偶啊
不要什麼行情道在做
我就是拽啊
不然咧
不然你告訴我為什麼我粉絲一百多萬
我跟你講你沒有
你不看我的股票
你會覺得我講話很討厭
135萬哪個
你看電視台我都比電視台多了
我也沒有去看電視台
從一年輕到現在也沒有人在捧我
因為我講話就討厭了
可是我講話實在啊
不在乎啊
我最喜歡這行業
我管你覺得我帥不帥
我管你覺得我講話淘不淘氣
重點是我準不準
你覺得看我的節目
我準你覺得看我的節目
我不準你不會看我的節目
而且說老實話我也不是壞人啊
我也不是壞人啊
有沒有
唯一在顏色喔
唯一喔
全台灣可以再證明一件事情怎麼樣
唯一不跟主力配合的
來
法院證明的喔
我還被牽解喔
他什麼自救會要告我喔
被牽解喔
我都想要反告回去耶
我是說真的
莫名其妙被人家聳動
你看那些人
清醒很多人清醒賣70元啦
被那些人害掉了
被那些慫恿我說我是壞人的
全台灣唯一法院證交所證明的喔
我要告我喔
哇 政教授還掉我的每個紀錄喔
不好意思 我沒有跟主力掛鉤的分析師
直接簽解
我的重點是喔
這個是全台灣第一個這樣子喔
什麼叫簽解
就是說
連不起訴都沒有
不起訴你還可以在意
喔 我想要再告他
是
簽解就是檢察官覺得
你不要鬧啦
你知道嗎
你這個東西完全證據不足
你不要亂告人家啦
是
你懂不懂
檢察官都不想傳話我啦
真的懂
懂
檢查官 數據官都不想傳望我
不是數據官 那個助理檢查官
檢視官都不想傳望我
或數據官
都不想傳望我
為什麼
不好意思 我就做很多
是我跟你講啊
折雖然是甩 但折的絕對不是壞的
好不好
OK
來 甩哥 折折
微星今天過125.5 核心被大盤拖累
你告訴我為什麼微星也穿新高
什麼009
對不起
我按到很慘的國具了
來
微星是代碼是
莉莉要幫我記
2377今天也差不多要拉尾盤
你告訴我這線型很漂亮
為什麼微星很漂亮
低基期跟矽晶圓一樣
以前好幾年前
環球金就快1000塊了
最近才給我突破1000塊
我不是說是不是低基期
莉莉 我不是說是低基期
你看中美金
2022年的時候我說中美金多少錢
你看一下喔 預約線
2022年中美金 看一看一看
我都不懂啊
你們一堆老師叫你買高級級股票幹什麼
2024年中美金230元有沒有看到
沒錯吧
沒錯
230元沒錯吧
對
2024年
請問你一下
現在多少
2024年的時候台灣股市差不多2萬多點啊
所以中美金是2萬多點
還是6萬點的中美金
是吧
2萬多點的中美金還是6萬多點
2萬多點
不要緊張
我丟給你問題一定很簡單的
2萬多點的中美金
廢話 這2萬多點的中美金難怪要買嘛
低級期的股票有什麼好講
我從頭到尾我都是全身脫光光給你耶
我真的很講道理啦
我跟你講你講不過我啦
因為我羅技很好啦
對就對錯就錯
關台風價這個也是一樣
你們不要覺得我去叮什麼藍綠白
我很討厭這件事情
我剛講一件事情啊
付錢 你不要說我是冠老闆
付錢給我的會員
哪一個希望禮拜五休息的啊
哪一個希望我禮拜五休息的啊
我不是冠老闆耶
我反而是幫他們打工耶
我就是問事
你看多少人禮拜五可以賣一個高點
那天本來要攢1400點
我都用負台值告訴你啊
我邏輯很好啊
我都用簡單的東西告訴你啊
是不是
唉
你告訴我為什麼全台灣最強的股票我都有
你第一天看我你覺得我在胡扯
哇
啊這實話有什麼胡扯的
是不是
責資源怎麼了
資源盤中還要漲了怎麼了
我們不要去評評別的老師好不好
我不知道你說誰好不好
我只會講老頭顧 新頭顧差別好不好
環球金713買
1180跑掉換中美金那也不錯啊
可惜你應該不是我問眼
好
李李今天唱歌要早點提
不然後面時間不夠
對 等一下我要去那個
齊交所
那個不是去那個
去上課
是
去公會上課
為什麼
上課沒辦法
大分醫師也是一樣
而且大家都認得我
不能翹課
不能代班
所以我等一下
那
等一下再20分鐘我就要結束了
好不好
OK
來看一下
這沒掛勾啦
但是沒掛勾直接
不是不起訴喔
不起訴
不起訴是
唉唷 檢察官查過了
覺得你沒問題
所謂的不起訴是
檢察官覺得
莫名其妙我就清清白白的
是比不起訴更輕微
根本就沒有什麼罪犯嫌疑喔
是
叫做 牽結
我也是學到新的法律制詞
牽結
這個還要
這個不只要一般檢察官喔
還有上面的檢察官喔
答應才行喔
是
還要牽結喔
為什麼 為什麼千姊
因為他們去行文證交所啦
去行文證交所啦
看有沒有查我的紀錄啊
不好意思
一個坑殺你的紀錄都沒有
不好意思 我不屑這種事
我如果要坑殺我第一件事
我美債先賣掉
我管你的臉皮厚
我就多賺兩億了 是不是
問題是我就不是中人啦
好不好
給他們雙鳴看一下字號
我剛才有講字號啦
你剛才跟他講啊 這邊
自己查
這個查不太到啦
但確骨就是有這個
這個騙不了人啦
好不好
那個書記官呢
我說可以直接問他也可以啊
好 律師都知道是怎樣
台北地檢署的確骨啊 好不好
這個騙不了人的
只是說
因為千姐說網路上
連網路上都沒記錄
但這是實際的
他們內部一定有資料 好不好
來
來來來
週五我參加GD電視台
GD真的很認真
我們莫老師真的績效都不錯
只是哲的最近績效特別好
我們莫老師都很認真啦 好不好
哲真的很照顧會員
快受不了記憶體要爛掉了
問你啦
阿阿阿你這個什麼
今天三星跌多少
三星都跌8% 10%了
三星啊 海力士啊 都跌啊
當然會很恐怖啊
好不好
我們來看一下啦
真的環球青看一下
我們念一下環球青好不好
730元買新嘛對不對
今天多少
其實1000
等於730
連我中途參加的會員喔
那天新會員而已喔
6月的新會員
6月6月6月6月喔
依依沒錯啊 6月是不是6月8號
沒錯 到現在幹嘛一個月嘛
一個月多一點點
6月到現在我都賺一倍了
而且禮拜五台風天我有沒有收環球金
被美觀收 被美觀合作投資代表是什麼
成熟製程也缺環球金 細晶圓這一塊
記憶體啊 晶片也缺空白的那種
細晶圓這一塊也是環球金 我說環球金展翻啦
因為成熟製程也要展價
先進製程也缺貨 也缺上油的
然後記憶體越缺 上面也缺啊
是不是
你們每天聽到什麼
什麼被動元件 二極體功率元件我說你們買那些幹嘛不夠我塞牙縫我問你一件事大老師什麼大老師就知道買全職股還能暫停板啦
我就大老師有什麼好講的
大老師就在買全職股
我這麼多位元你叫我買什麼股票
買什麼功率原件整個二極體
我跟你講塞牙縫都不夠
我還真的不想買
塞牙縫都不夠
不要問我那小型股
我要小型股我們自己可以當主力大戶
我直接拉展庭
我每天可以拉展庭啊
我不屑做那種錢
我跟你說說我真的不屑做那種錢
也不代表別人介紹就是跟主力配合
只是我真的不做這種事情啊
因為那不一定幫得了你啊
我問你環球精你買幾億
還是一樣下車
是不是
是
這大老師啊
含水會結凍
頭顧界最大老師
從以前到西漢最紅的就是我
不好意思
真的是我
恭喜
6488環球金一開盤就暫停鎖止再穿利率新高
我買進到現在
最高已經獲利170%
我持續看好他 手上持獲利需報
不過姊姊也要不要太那麼臭屁
我要告訴你
我也不是每天都那麼準
只是最近真的很準
好不好 我也不是每天都那麼準
可是最近真的從4月翻多以來
我有夠準
是
準到誇張
真的很誇張
我那時候因為我翻多它漲上去的嘛
我快氣死你知道嗎
他問我想說我就買第一季期的股票
那個機 那個誰
那個你動不動 那個誰
喔 那個環球晶
不是環球晶 環球晶展一倍就算了
是
被動元件也展一倍嘛
展100%以上嘛 差不多100%
那個聯發科 對 聯發科
從1400多 展到快5000塊
也展100多%
環球晶也賺100多%
你告訴我哪個分析師
通通都這樣報都報100%
幫我練一下簡訊啦
幫我練一下簡訊
好 7月13日星期一
恭喜6488環球晶
一開盤就漲停
縮死
再創歷史新高
我們買進到現在最高
已經獲利170%
我持續看好它
手上持股
獲利續爆
恭喜大家轉打錢啦
這170%
我希望是普通會員簡訊
普通會員
他有時候
我會叫他買個舞檔
可是有些特別會員就是
清代會員是中壓
而且普通會員也有
特工會員也有
AI也有
簡訊會員
特工會員也有
我愛美元不是中美金
我中愛美金
美金嘛 美金鈔票嘛
中愛美金 你看這是送分題啊
中美金漲停 漲停漲停
是不是
我說最強是環球金
中美金
它漲上去中美金會噴
我們講過類似的話
有
有啊
買進5483中美金
我上禮拜上還在買喔
颱風天還在買喔
颱風天前兩天還買喔
207 213.5
還在買喔
我講的是還在買喔
我自己買
我賺32%
中美金真的很丟臉
賺32%
跟我精彩比真的丟臉
可是你要搞清楚
我是最近才買的
你知道嗎
我是先買環球金
後來才買我愛美元中美金
恭喜我愛美元
五四八萬中美金
股價一開盤就暫停鎖死
串快兩年新高
我們台風價
請還連兩天加碼
連兩天再次加碼
有沒有
連兩天喔
對
讓你不只賣愛美元
還賺到台幣啊
我買進到現在
最高已經獲利32%
一開盤就暫停
各位你們開不開心
全台灣現在最強的股票
就是我國中的股票
都在手裡
精彩也是一樣
維新也是一樣
你告訴我有誰股票比我強
有誰啦
好不好
有誰我們講實在話啦
有誰啦
好不好
No.1只能夠公開啦
其實半買半享受啦
你們大概知道什麼股票啦
我不想講的啦好不好
就矽晶圓的股票怎麼講的
對啊
來來
這跟大家講
來來來
今年的會費超值
對
我也不知道批評別人
我說今年我真的有夠準
忘記講 我四月翻隊
忘記講 我記憶體年初的時候
還有下車一次 下得很漂亮
也是一堆翻倍股票
我今年 我今年
我跟你說真的
今年 哲哲
投顧這幾年 再摸這幾年
今年的績效真的有夠強
強爆了
強到誇張
你還不趕快參加會員
哲哲 你現在這麼強
我以後會不會賺不到錢
我跟你講啦 2月有人這樣講啦
3月有人這樣講啦
4月有人這樣講
哲哲你賺那麼多了會不會不賺的
5月有人這樣講啊
6月也這樣講
7月今天股票一堆跌停板
我的股票一堆漲停板啦
你幹嘛想那麼多喔
今年就是我的什麼
我好的一年你趕快進場
想那麼多幹什麼
是不是
來
今年最好賺 真的
不只股票準 氣象也準
屌打氣象專家
你知道什麼 細項也準嘛
因為我告訴你一件事情
我就是一個獨立思考的男人
我不會受一個限制
我跟你講我之前有沒有跟他講
我說你們如果是
你在講一次 我在講一次講十遍以上
如果你現在是一個駕駛員
尤其是一個計程車司機
只要司機駕駛員
就是特斯拉已經準備要期待你
第二個我說你英語的
跟你是那種家教業的 補習班的
你要記得一件事情
這件事情以後工作很多人會取代你
尤其我說英語翻譯
我說你又不用學語言了
莉莉無三這樣講對不對
是
你不用學語言
你聽說你的英語很好啦
好不好
如果早十年的話是真的很吃香
現在沒有辦法
我跟你講適時
來我們看一下
AI更厲害
蛤
我們來看一下喔
我們看這一段喔
你看這一段喔
聲音
欸先把它關掉了
有開聲音嗎
有
我們看這一段
就ChryGPT最新版本的喔
上禮拜開始的喔
來喔
他叫他
我直接結識喔
他叫你怎麼樣
翻譯啊
就是我講中文
他翻譯成日文 你有沒有看到
他剪了喔 來喔
你有沒有看到 他一直在旁邊講話喔
不是說你一段我一段喔
是你講話馬上講話
你講話馬上講話
好像有翻譯官在旁邊你知道嗎
是
那很貴耶
那種其實翻譯都一兩千塊的喔
一小時一兩千塊 來喔
他講中文直接TrackGP
把他講日文 來
3 2
聽聽要聲音看問題喔 3 2 1
台灣呢 有這個颱風假
今天是放颱風假
那大家在家裡呢
可能可以去看電影
追劇一下
然後在家裡煮個飯啊
或是休息一下之類的
但是其實我現在沒有辦法休息
因為我的產品呢已經快要上線了
所以說我必須要在家裡努力
欸 剛才那個聲音沒問題吧對不對
啊 那個伊伊有沒有聽到
小孩有沒有聽到 很誇張對不對
是不是很恐怖
超誇張
其實翻譯了 你們怎麼辦
啊 我叫你買AI啊
所以AI怎麼會是泡沫
是記憶體長太多了
AI怎麼會是泡沫
AI不是泡沫
很多人被取代了
所以你這時候投資股票
你就是不會取代
比你買保險好
我都不懂耶
所謂的保險意義是什麼
保險意義是以防萬一
你們怎麼為什麼
哦
就是我買一個固定的投資險
投資相關投資保單
你們不要那麼簡單
不知道每個人都想的事情
你要想是什麼叫保險
保險是你這個行業的
你要被人家取代的
那你要買什麼
買AI股啊
被取代就算了
反正你裝上退休啊
你看這很恐怖
那還有語法哦
來看一下哦
他叫你怎麼樣
我會在你文法一出錯當下
他就說我要跟你訓練口說
是
那個現在不是劉璇口說嗎
有沒有
真人跟你口說對不對
對
你注意聽
你聽得出來
他是真人還假人
你是假的人啊
是AI喔
他一講你英文的時候
你文法錯誤
他就糾正你喔
一講英文的時候
文法錯誤就糾正你
是不是很像真人
是
真人家叫很貴耶
來 3 2 1
第一課打斷
OK so
Yesterday after work
I go to the market
Went
Oh OK
I went
不是,他說不是 go to work,是 I went to work,有沒有,用過去式你知道嗎?
I went to the market and then...
Yesterday,他故意講文法錯,他説 yesterday,然後過去式,他說 I go to work,或是 I go to market,他說 I went to market, the market,有沒有,過去式,他直接結識啊,口說啊,真的喔?
那多少錢
一個月六百塊
那你覺得喊你英文家教
數學家教
英文口說
理 物理 化學
統統都可以
還可以醫學嘗試
你爸媽生病了
還可以比你醫生厲害
我說真的
有些醫生沒有耐心
我說有些啦
有些真的很厲害
沒有耐心沒辦法
台灣的健保支出造成的
六百元
我會覺得太便宜了
一個月六萬元我都願意付
你知道嗎
你知道我跟你講我等一下可以看那個東西
比如說我看到今天有一個人寫
溫體牛肉很好吃
然後他是由下晚上拍
是
然後招牌真的看不到字喔
可是他可以從旁邊的周章的環境
然後去GPT可以知道他在哪邊
是哪一間店嗎
對對對
真的假
真的很厲害
這邊是木質系的木頭
哇很恐怖啊
太厲害了
我傳給這個東西給你看
你可能覺得胡扯
我沒有辦法傳給你看
這...
那很恐怖啊
來來來
那很恐怖喔
我會睡覺
轉給你看圖片
馬上給你看喔
好不好
這你看這具面
所以你們不懂
AI泡沫
你們不懂
記憶體很爛
不過記憶體喔
是基礎線圖
就像
怎麼樣
我就說過
背道圓圓圓圓圓圓1.0產區
我有參與到
是
那個
我參與到
我那時候賺很多啦
下去也賠到啦
那個殘龍揚明萬海
那個等於被動元件2.0啦
現在被動元件3.0也要慘劇啦
2.0我基本上我不算瘦三道
好不好 我七進七出
所以我跟你講
我真的頭腦裡面是活字典
所以我技巧越來越好很正常你知道嗎
你聽懂嗎 莉莉
是
我技巧越來越好很正常
因為你同樣的分析師
你找特別有經驗的
你看好像這樣
你看人家這樣子喔 好不好
我問你來這裡你知道什麼餐廳嗎
不知道啊
查他出來
天哪 太厲害了
在我們公司附近
查出來 這樣子你知道
不過卻GAMAN也查不出來
卻GPT查出來
所以卻GPT是因為又贏了你知道嗎這樣你知道你告訴我這樣吃到什麼餐廳好厲害喔我看到人家說很好吃我想說我是我是吃貨我最喜歡吃好吃的東西
工作壓力大一定要吃東西
吃東西的時候不好意思
有時候哲哲沒有理各位
不好意思
因為很多粉絲看到我就這樣
看我
然後我都不知道要不要打招呼
也沒關係啦
就彼此有保留隱密空間
也謝謝你啦
不過哲哲都愛你們好不好
這樣懂不懂
這樣妳看不出來那張圖吧
看不出來
妳告訴我
那個字在哪邊 再看一次喔
請問你這個招牌 看這招牌
這樣看得出來喔
真的看不出來
它查出來耶
好厲害
後來我去對照一下那張圖
我看正的看起來
如果下面這樣拍就這樣厲害
查出來你看到字嗎
就像天花板你也看得出來
做這個餐廳很好吃
站那麼多 現在幾分了
趕快趕快 我今天要早點
我要好公民要去上課了
來來 我們先來看一下我們大家的對話
馬上了 馬上
你看一下喔
今天被動員件是一堆跌停板
什麼國具啊 什麼信倉店啊 是不是
怎麼看台積電營收
我跟你講 台積電營收創立新高
但不必研究 為什麼
因為我才不管台積電營收
我只要管這禮拜四
台積電
法書會
法書會年度營收會不會從年增30%
年度的美元營收會不會從年增30%
變年增40%
它漲價是漲真的
只要涨價 涨著等 敢涨價代表怎麼樣
代表台積電這是完真的
代表營收創新高
40%很多耶
那台積電就有機會賣向2800啦
你聽懂嗎 OK嗎
矽金追不到OIN無人機比較有機會
再講無人機
再打你自己的廣告
我給你封鎖你
我股票比你強多了
不要來亂好不好
不要打廣告好不好
超富二什麼的
欸 別說沒有
那個超富二是一個網紅是不是
都祝福他啦
你們不要一直重複的事情打廣告
我的股票都寫不完的 好不好
招招台積電法說 改他禮拜四
你告訴我啦 謝謝你喔
謝謝你看
為什麼可能台風天的關係
所以莉莉妳看是我
我怎麼造假
我這邊一堆人
有時候比我 某部分比我專業
直接告訴我世界先進的營收
告訴我誰的營收
我有問題是不是
對
是不是 好不好
來來
感謝招招台積電法說
重點是法說營收不重要
好不好
怎麼看國劇
我送你一句話
國劇嘛是不是
國劇捷運產
疊體嘛對不對
沒錯吧
來
沒救啦
這個頭這麼大
啊我就說
我業界都知道被動元件
然後什麼技術含量
你們在胡扯
又不像記憶體一樣
擴產很快
記憶體擴產麻煩耶
你們在胡扯嘛
炒作嘛
300到1塊1000人
就可以走了
你是不是
我是真的第一波被坑殺的
2016年吧
2016年 2018年 很慘啦
國劇從那個1000元啦
從200元找到1000元啦
這從1000元變那個 被前期害死了
我特別有經驗 特別有感覺
所以為什麼這次我見好就收
你們要找分析師要找有經驗好不好
有被
有不小心被坑殺過 你知道
2018年有沒有看到
月線有沒有看到
怎麼樣
從50塊有沒有看到
是
周線來看一下
來來
從50塊
有沒有看到
50塊這邊
98塊 賺到1000塊
再從1000塊跌到200塊
跌到200塊 扯不扯
天啊
國劇的老闆很會那種財務操作啦
我不要講多講多話
變成批皮人家啦
我們做好我們的事情就好
我們讓我們帶會員
進進出出賺這一筆
好不好
國劇有賺錢走喔
需要秀簡訊嗎
比如操作計下表
如果照假我下載一鞠躬
你看聯發科賺100多%
賺到4270
國劇也賺快100%
有沒有看到
是不是
都出掉都開心
你說哲哲國劇我出的很低啊
我賺一倍不能出啊
來來你看我當初怎麼預告啊
看一下
看一下你會起雞皮疙瘩啊
你說國劇怎麼看啊
來看一下
國劇跟信倉電
因為記憶體
背負原件今天全部都基本上跌
都那個跌停啊對不對
看一下啊
看一下
6月15日有沒有到
6月15日
上個月之前有沒有到
那時候都900多塊
兩個都900多塊啊
來
我看我的預告喔
好不好
這邊的原件重點是他們能不能再展一倍
我跟你講同樣是940
國具跟環球金
來我再次預告
同樣是940喔
那時候兩個都940喔
6月等一下
6月這樣
該是15號還是這樣
該是6月15吧
好像6月15
6月中旬
6月15號附近我講的同樣是940
我再次預告
你看我再次預告喔
誰會展一倍喔
你看一下
我預言家
所以氣象報告還好啦
我都能預言了
環球金再攢一倍的機率比大於國具
好不好
技巧這句話
一個940、950吧
我們下贊帖啦
下贊帖一個950、一個940
環球金攢一倍多少
11900嘛
同樣兩個誰的先到1900到2000
環球金1900環球金有機會到
兩個價錢一樣嘛
一個950、一個940差不多
OK
你不覺得我很敢預告嗎
我很敢預告耶
你去跟我講
誰比我厲害
不要說我現在有環球金
我現在有矽金源
我有台聖科 我有中美金
算多少 你告訴我
業界誰算多少
我不知道攻擊別人 我也不喜歡
我不屑
我不喜歡人家攻擊我
所以我不想攻擊人家
可是講事實是誰
環球金買的比我漂亮
00981A那時候
我不是要攻擊人家
我想念這
真的啦
你說有人賣掉
我管主動型ETF怎麼想
我就是要買它
那時候咧
900多 快要1900了
你看現在
900多
你還漲到1200
那你多少要1200你還不出
你看現在每天跌
是不是
是
那個6488環球晶
你自己看
今天1485
再兩三天的話就要18001900了
今天暫停鎖死
是不是
全部暫停鎖死
中美晶那些什麼合晶
是不是今天暫停板
禮拜五我也講到合晶
我不是細菌也要漲真的有沒有
是不是合晶
我也可以買這一堆
可是我買最好的
中美晶環球晶
還有台股No.1
你知道是什麼股票啦
不知道也不重要
要參加我會員好不好
好 我們就要結束了
現在幾分了 8分
精彩練一下簡訊 來來
精彩
環球晶應該那麼多展停板了對不對
環球晶 看賺多少
看一下
170%環球晶喔 沒錯吧
今天展停板鎖死喔
對
2 4 6 8
19個展
17個展停板 什麼時候
17個
170%
中美金32% 因為比較晚買
你看維西 金彩賺92%
金彩賺92%還沒走
我就這麼貪心
我就說過 如果你股價沒有想要賺一倍
拜託不要來找我
你如果要賺20-30% 你找別人
很多老師可以表演
哇 有最強的股票
但實際的%數就這麼少
或者實際%數跟你講100%
他敢跟你講說
所有的股票會員 所有簡訊會員買嗎
我環球金 我所有簡訊會員買
我所有等級會員買啊
我記得沒有錯 金財也是一樣喔
中美金也是一樣喔
誰敢這樣講嘛
不要表演 我不需要表演
不是那種 哇 根本就賺到十幾二十percent
假如甜甜漲聽班
或賺一百percent 沒幾個會員買
我不是
我剛才講 剛才台積電法說會
你看就多少人看著我
一百多萬的人見證我的歷史
我告訴你 台灣股市會拉回
有可能拉回
我不去預設立場
因為韓國股市太慘了
可是我最要跟你講的是什麼
全台灣計校誰要比我強
你關這個被動原件你看一好一壞就差那麼多了
下贊帖
重點我管你國巨怎麼樣
我就不能賺一倍走嗎
我說我要當什麼
我說你感情不要當渣男
股市要當什麼
渣男
股市要當渣男啦
把人家精華去拿
精華的那一段拿走就好
剩下給人家啦
人家謝謝你
你丟給他謝謝你
哎呀呀呀你這個你不要了
好嘞
我就不要國巨怎麼樣
我就不要
我就不要聯發科怎麼樣
我賺夠了不行喔
我丟給你啊
我去買低基期的啊
所以為什麼我一堆股票
今天低基期漲上去啊
你告訴我
2377維新為什麼漲
低基期啊
笑死人了
這麼低的股票
是不是
還有什麼
3374啊
精彩也是一樣啦
今天沒時間講世界先進好不好
我今天沒時間我要去錄影了
不是去那個開會了
我要去上課了
我們分析師
不好意思
跟網紅不一樣啊
我們主管機關規定
我們要上課
你知道嗎
我們是守法的公民
所以你不找合法分析
同樣的錢你為什麼不找合法分析師
我不懂耶 怎麼相信別人
好不好 記憶體不用擔心啦
不行該走就走
怎麼走 怎麼進場
找我好不好
所以你去想想看你要專案分析師
我不去四個萬馬奧炮
你想清楚全台灣最強的股票
上禮拜五精彩 有誰比精彩還強
展停創新高有價有量
今天有誰比矽金運還強
我禮拜五加班跟你講矽金運很強
有誰比矽金運還強
台股No.1 展停中美金
都一架鎖死了
什麼合金我都有跟你講
不要給我胡扯
都暫停
都一架鎖死
我環球金拉回
不能怎麼樣我就買
我管別人怎麼想
所以到底有誰比我強啦
我要更強的股票啦
歡迎來臨下請
0.866-8085
或我叫我賴斯去我
你再不跟著我
你會後悔一輩子
預祝各位能夠賺大錢
掰掰
本节目资料仅供参考
投资人应独立判断
审慎评估并自负投资风险
谢谢大家